was war zuerst da das huhn oder das ei
diese frage klären wir hier und jetzt
ein für allemal
[Musik]
und aus ein stück bühne
irgendwann vor langer zeit muss es das
allererste huhn oder das allererste
eingegeben haben dennoch gab es ja nicht
schon immer dass holen so wie wir es
kennen ist übrigens der erste lebende
verwandte das kind in der wüste was aus
ihnen geworden ist da die dinos schon
eier gelegt haben ist das natürlich viel
älter als das tun die korrekte frage
müsste also lauten was war zuerst da das
huhn oder das hühnerei das hole muss ich
also irgendwann als spezies entwickelte
neue spezies entwickeln sich durch
kleine veränderungen in der dna ihrer
vorgänger
das kopieren der dna bei der
fortpflanzung ist niemals 100 prozent
rabatt
es kommt immer zu kleinen sogenannten
mutationen manche mutationen können zum
beispiel zu krankheiten führen andere
mutationen können aber auch vorteilhaft
führte organismus sein
durch so eine dna mutationen kann ein
organismus zum beispiel fässer an seine
umwelt angepasst werden solche
mutationen können dann verehrt werden
und sich zu einer neuen spezies
entwickeln natürlich ist evolution ein
langer gradueller prozess
das heißt die direkten vorfahren des
huhns waren dem genetisch schon sehr
ähnlich und tricks schon sehr unähnlich
aber irgendwann wurde das erste von zwei
nicht hühnern erzeugt und zwar so die
dna des menschen schwer maß und die dna
des weiblichen eisbären kombiniert uns
entsteht die sogenannte zugute die quote
ist die allererste zelle des hühner
babys in jedem tier und auch in uns
enthält jede zelle genau dieselbe dna
und der zugute der aller ersten zelle
als irgendwann verhalten sich zwei nicht
hühner und die dna ihrer zielgruppe
enthielt die nötigen mutation um das
erste darzustellen
vor dieser die quote gab es nur nicht
hühner
die tote war die erste zelle mit grün ag
n a und da sich diese quoten zelle im
mai beendet ist die antwort auf das
rätsel das ei war
aber jetzt seid ihr gefragt das war die
biologie dazu aber eine sache des
biologisch nicht geklärt und zwar wie
genau ein kühner definiert ist denn wie
gesagt geht es hier nicht um kunst
sondern um buhnen und hühner
wir haben geklärt dass das erste wohl
mit der ersten bühne zugute entstand
aber darf man das ei in dem iran wächst
schon hühner einen oder ist erst das all
das dieses erste hund lebt das erste
richtige hühnereis wenn das so wäre dann
war das huhn
doch zuerst und hier kommen wir zur
entscheidenden frage was ist ein
hühnerei ist ein hühnerei ein ei das von
einem huhn gelegt wird oder ist ein
hühnerei ein ei aus dem all nun schlüpft
die frage mit klarer wenn man sie sich
bisschen absurd darstellt stellt euch
vor ein hase würde ein ei legen und aus
dem ei schlüpft an ihre ist dieses als
1001 oder ein eagle eye stimmt die oben
up oder schreibt es in die kommentare
und erklären wie diese frage ein für
alle mal schön schlau und damit wünsche
ich euch ein wunderschönes rosa fest mit
oder ohne eier jedenfalls wissen jetzt
was sie in zukunft antworten könnt wenn
euch jemand mit dem handy oder ein
problem kommt hier sehen uns wieder
nicht nur noch sagt bis dahin bleibt
sicher